we have other news this morning
including a decision that allows nearly
5 million children to get a third dose
of pfizer's coping vaccine a cdc
advisory committee has endorsed booster
shots for kids aged 15 12 to 15 excuse
me who had their second dose at least
five months ago the cdc is strongly
recommending boosters for 16 and 17 year
olds as well a record number of children
with covet are being hospitalized more
than 600 a day over the past week
and more news from the cdc the data
there paints a dire picture of what's
likely to come as those omicron cases
surge the agency expects up to around 54
000 people to be hospitalized every day
by the end of this month that's a big
number nikki batisse went inside an icu
in teaneck new jersey that's just
outside new york city and she has more
on that part of the story
it's all hands on deck at holy name
medical center in teaneck new jersey how
have the numbers of cova patients
changed from just before the holidays to
now just before the holidays we were
under 30. yesterday we were over 90. so
we've seen a significant increase dr
michelle aceto is the chief nursing
officer right now 106 employees are out
sick 26 of them nurses for those at work
this is still a big part of the job
description holding up cell phones so
patients can facetime their loved ones
see that
care for patients day in and day out and
then work so hard
and not win the battle
it's it's a lot nearly 6 thousand
hospital staff members across new jersey
have gotten kovid since christmas the
state is asking its national guard and
fema for help with staffing fourteen
hospitals in the state face a critical
staffing shortage at least three more
are expected to by the end of the week
that's as the state sees more than 700
patients in the icu nurse lauren
boniello has worked at holy name for
almost 10 years she says the pandemic
has been incredibly difficult as they've
lost patients and coworkers to covid in
the beginning of the pandemic we lost an
employee who everyone was very familiar
of and really worked alongside
it was a challenging day it was a very
emotional day but it was something that
we got through together in that moment
what's going through your mind
sorry
and almost two years later they're still
pushing on what do people need to know
about what you and your staff and nurses
are going through
i think they need to know that we are
here for
any patient that walks through that door
michelle aceto says right now her
biggest concern for her staff is burnout
after a two-year seemingly never-ending
cycle she says right now there are 80
covet patients here at holy name of
those in the icu all but two are
unvaccinated and the two who are have
comorbidities that left them prone to
severe illness
nikki batis reporting we thank you nikki
another important reminder about the
work that the frontline workers do every
day to save our lives